why did you decide to detransition was  there something that happened part of it  was I started loving myself I started  really digging in and understanding the  concept Understanding Psychology like I  said I started going for a master's  degree in mental health counseling and I  learned so much if anybody noticed I've  been wearing flannel shirts all summer  and 90 degree weather because I was  trying to cover myself up and just kind  of hide and haven't worn makeup for a  long time like I was just at the point  where it was like a purge like beyond  belief if anything even looked even  slightly feminine I would just throw it  away or burn it because I just it didn't  disgust me but it made me remember my  old self who was just it was wrong it  made me remember the pitfalls I fell  into about the self-hatred and the  self-loathing about esteem you know lack  of esteem or even ego comes into a